qu'est-ce jacques et geneviève de
fontenay elie semoun
oh
mon amour
shenzhen de penser elie semoun
quel bonheur et vous avoir tous ici ce
soir est pour cette dernière émission
voilà alors geneviève
ben oui j'ai pesé sur le coeur gros et
c'est vrai je me rappelle j'ai vu venir
la première fois en 98 aces comme ça
1900 et on arrivait way rigoler ensemble
ton et citations oui il y en a eu des
bons moments tiré que je te remercie
parce que je crois que tu as contribué à
la popularité que j'ai ma main
vu défiler des records
allez les gars tout événement car
jean-louis à combronde jamais je ne
viens pas souvent choqué c'était logique
de sa part que de pareils on a passé de
bons moments ensemble à es6 site
rappelle le petit mot que tu m'avais mis
un jour dans ma loge je vais très bien
je vais mieux je t aime en secret voilà
il avait dit geneviève je t'aime en
secret ouais ça l'à beaucoup touché
et en ce qui concerne thierry je te
remercie parce que tu as toujours
accueillis j'ai eu marre et va encore il
ya quelques temps superbe il ya un truc
que j'ai jamais fait oh non non non
quand même pas
les cowboys comme ça catherine venue à
mon âge c'est permis ouais tu embrasses
bien est encore pire que la rougeole est
sur les lèvres
merci aux cicatrices
jacques gaye maintenant benoît 16
rebonds mais on passe vite on est promis
qu'il viendrait
il gare sa harley ils arrivent en suisse
il ya un rituel dans sa dernière
émission c'est que les invités pose une
question alors en est à moi en
commençant par mois c'est normal je
t'écoute geneviève j'ai pas tellement de
questions à se poser avant j'étais venu
pour te remercier way avant tout besoin
une question c'est le moment ou jamais
est-ce que tu m'aimes ah oui mais
j'étais sûr que tu te dis match était
rejoué lundi la parole demi molle la de
fontenay la célèbre la patate chaude
non je suis suis très touchée ce soir tu
vois non mais c'est pas très jeune
anglais c'est pas trés v6 parce que
quand même bon c'est vrai que librement
sur une femme a vécu les bons moments
ensemble
mais je crois qu'on compte mieux les
saloperies je vais commencer élection
miss univers sons paris-première chopin
la nuit d'hier n 15 juillet alors il
paraît une question à thierry ardisson
questions allant
m
thierry
oh ben moi qu'elle n'essaie pas vrai
c'est stupide et même entretenu laisse
parler les basiques gagner un peu de
temps pour trouver ma question à léonie
la voix qui est la miss france qui t'a
le plus marqué celui qui pose quelle est
la miss france qui t'a le plus marqué et
ledit gosselin parce qu'elle a des
couilles
c'est l'animal c'est l'animal est petit
à des ailes avec des petites plumes et
vol
comment s'appelle-t-il j'ai envie de
dire à ceux-là je pensais aux marrons
chauds six mois c'est sur une fausse
piste
il est vraiment
enfin son or orange en des cassettes
cette semaine j'ai retrouvé des images
de toits complètement par hasard on va
les voir mais avant 1 2 3